hello and welcome to ed talks with khan
academy
i'm kristen decervo the chief learning
officer here at khan academy and today i
am excited to welcome judy heumann who
is an international disability rights
activist and look forward to talking to
her about her work and
how we can help learners with
disabilities succeed in the education
space
before we get started i want to remind
you that khan academy is a non-profit
and we are able to continue to do our
work thanks to donations from folks like
you if you are able to we appreciate
every dollar that you are able to give
if you go to khanacademy.org
donate you will find an easy way to make
those donations
in addition we want to thank some
companies who helped us during the covet
19 crisis to continue to maintain the
quality content that we offer and those
include bank of america at t
google.org novartis fastly and general
motors thank you
next if you want to listen to
other guests we've had or to re-listen
to this episode in an audio version you
can find a podcast version of our
ed talks in homeroom chats under
homeroom with sal the podcast so take a
look for that wherever you get your
podcasts
as i said today i am excited to welcome
judy heumann
she is an international disability
rights activist she's also an author
she's
written more than one book but her
latest is rolling warrior the incredible
sometimes awkward true story of a rebel
girl on wheels who helped spark a
revolution and this is a book aimed for
for uh kids were about 10 years old so
that's a good space if you have kids on
your holiday lists uh take a look for
this option welcome judy
hi so happy to be with you
thanks for joining us so let's take it
out quickly
yeah i was gonna say
in addition to
that book the original book which came
out
in uh
2020
is for adults and it's called it's not
that there's anything pornographic and
it's just
the the um
the writing is more for adults
so it's called being human
an unrepentant memoir of a disability
rights activist and
one of the differences between this book
and the rolling warrior is
we had a group of young people
work with us on
the transition from the adult book to
the youth book
and so you'll see
not only is a cover difference the title
is different the layout is different the
chapter names are different the story is
essentially the same
but it's for a younger reading audience
and then
for all of you who are
japanese readers
um
the japanese have come out
with a translation
of being human
and here it is so if any of you
are in japan or no people in japan
uh same book
in japanese
um i was very happy that people that i
knew in japan from the disability
community
wanted to
translate the book and you can get
the book
also in great britain they have
um
this is their version
same book sorry guys a little more
boring cover
but same with barely's life
and if i could also say
um i'm one of the people
in
an account academy
nominated film
uh called [ __ ] camp
and uh
i think
[ __ ] camp is a really important film and
it's probably for
um 10 or 11 year olds and up
um and
it's r rated
so some schools
have not been able to show it because of
that until you know the upper grades of
high school but certainly all of you
should be watching it um it's a great
documentary it's won the peabody award
and
many others and it is as i said a
documentary and i think from an
educational perspective
while it's not talking about pedagogy it
has a number of people like myself who
had our disabilities when we were
younger
and i think it allows you to
in part see
some of the differences that existed
in the 40s 50s 60s and early 70s before
there was any legislation in the united
states that was meaningful and made it a
requirement that disabled children go to
school
excellent well you just uh took a whole
lot of my recommendations
i recommend all those things but but
particularly i found um
crypt camp to be an excellent piece of
work and also recommended
so
speaking of your story
let's start there tell us a little bit
about
how your experiences growing up
influenced who you are today
well
i was 18 months old when i had polio
and i learned when i was 36
that a doctor had told my parents that
he recommended they put me in an
institution when i was two
and the reason i tell you i didn't learn
about this till i was way an adult
was my parents never wanted me to know
this
which i think
was a very good thing actually um
but they're
they're german
they were they passed away german jewish
uh refugees
and um
so
for any of you who know the history um
under hitler and in the holocaust the
first group of people that they were
killing were disabled people
and so um
my parents obviously
because they also lost all their
families
were um
reconstructing and starting a new family
so
we were on the road to
from my parents perspective
raising me like they intended to raise
me if i didn't have a disability
but they began to realize that that
wasn't really the case
i mean accessibility in the 40s
50s 60s started changing
in brooklyn and new york city but still
not significantly i started using a
wheelchair
i used braces and crutches
but i wasn't really able to walk
independently
my arms i'm polio quadriplegic my arms
are not very strong
so i wasn't
using a motorized wheelchair
because they didn't even exist then
they started slowly coming in in the 60s
and then more in the 70s and i did get a
motorized wheelchair in the late 60s and
i've used one ever since
um and we could go back to that but for
those of you who
work with children who have physical
disabilities
mobility is something which is very
important
and um
it's
sometimes people
look at using a motorized wheelchair
as something which is not going to
advance your strength
but i think the reality is is that
we really need to look at what children
need
and one of the things children need is
to be able to be
as independent as possible
with their friends
and also you know i didn't get a
motorized wheelchair until my late teens
2021.
so i had never gone across the street by
myself
i had never just gone out
and walked around the neighborhood i
couldn't take a bus
i couldn't take a train they weren't
accessible
all of those things you know from an
educational perspective
kids beginning as they're getting older
to go across the street and visit a
neighbor and as they're getting even
older taking a bus to go someplace
being able to go to the store by
themselves those are things i couldn't
do
by myself
now of course i can
but i really think you know when we
think about education there's the
classroom but there's life and life also
does impact
so um
when my mother took me to school
the principal denied me the right to go
to school
because he said i would be a fire hazard
so this again was before we had any of
these laws in the u.s
and so i was home
i wasn't like home schooled
because there wasn't anything like that
at that time my mother was teaching me
and then in the first grade a teacher
started coming
to the house twice a week once for an
hour once for an hour and a half
so until the middle of the fourth grade
i was getting two and a half hours a
week of educational training
then i went to segregated education
special ed classes
and quite frankly they were
not comparable to the same classes for
non-disabled children
and then i went to college
and wanted to be a teacher
um
was denied my teaching license
because in writing they said i couldn't
walk
so then i sued
the board of education and the judge
remanded a case back to the board of ed
who did grant me another medical
and i did get my teaching license and i
taught in new york for three years but
during all that time
i was
learning and when you look at [ __ ] camp
and read the book
you'll get a chance to understand
what many of us were going through and
still go through and that is
discrimination that we experience
and
what
both our families and
we as individuals as we're growing older
what responsibilities we need to take
for ourselves
and how
we individually and more collectively
have been working together
not only to
improve
the system
but also to give ourselves
stability and confidence
because you know one of the issues that
this is not just disability issue
but race or religion which is different
or sexual orientation
whatever
um and disabled people come from all of
those categories
black asian
indigenous latino gay straight muslim
whatever
so
i think what's important
about work for those of you who are
doing anything in education
is really to understand some of the
very important additional issues
that
is are beneficial
for families and
disabled kids
to be able to
get the kind of support they need
so that assuming they're getting a
decent education
they
are not fearful
of going out into the world getting a
job and being competitive
yeah that issue of establishing your own
independence is such a key
both psychological issue and uh issue
that we all go through growing up but it
has different
kind of elements as we're thinking about
learners with disabilities
when you think about students students
yeah yeah
right right yeah
thinking about schools as as many of the
folks who are joining us today are you
know related to either schools or
teaching and elements
just kind of broadly how do you think
about the what are the needs of learners
with disabilities in schools what should
folks that are in schools be thinking
about in order to ensure that those
students get that education that they
they need
well you know the word disability is so
broad
yeah and so
there isn't
you know one approach for all kids
now that's also true for non-disabled
children
so
what we really need to understand is
every child is different
and
whether or not
you have any kids that are defined as
having a disability as i was saying
not all kids learn the same way and part
of what
we're needing to do is to
enable the teacher to
have knowledge and confidence
that they can look at what the needs of
the child are
and
i do believe we
need to be getting our universities
to be doing a better job of teaching
teachers and administrators
about how to have effective classes
and for teachers to
have some more knowledge about the types
of needs that some
students identified with disabilities
or not i mean when i taught
i i didn't have
there were no children who were
identified in my three years of teaching
who had disabilities
on the other hand
categorically quite a number of them did
um they had things like
learning disabilities or dyslexia
at a time when those words weren't even
known in the system
right you know i think it's
teachers knowing how to teach reading
because that's a very big issue
um in younger grades
that um i think phonetic learning is
very important and it's been shown to
really help
children
learn to read and also
in some cases
not result in the child needing
additional services
but if they do at least you know
that you've clearly been working with
the child and the family
to
help them get the kind of
supports that they need
i think
having
an assistant in a classroom
which may happen if you have a disabled
student
can be very helpful and
trying to have that assistant not just
work with the disabled kids sometimes it
needs to be that way but i would say
by and large
you want the child to be in the
classroom and be
as integrated and as included as
possible
and i think it's not being afraid
i think it's really
not only learning about the child but
learning about
the disability that the child may have
and you know really be there because you
believe
that the child can learn
like the other children in your
classroom
so i think those are all very important
points
and it may mean that you need to
you know get some literature look at
some of the organizations
that are out there that could provide
you with assistance
um
but
i think the most
important thing is
that the classrooms of today meaning now
2021
um
continue to change every year
with the diversity in our schools
cultural diversity language diversity
food diversity
i mean i'll tell you a story
um second year i was teaching
first year i taught special ed
and
i was an itinerant
which meant
the teacher didn't want to teach a class
they asked me
and so i
was teaching a myriad of classes
the second year i had a second grade
class
and um
one day
one of my students
who was a very good student i really
liked her
um she was kind of having a little rough
day
and her mother would bring her to school
and pick her up
and so when she came to pick her up this
day
i said you know could you please speak
to diana
and just tell her that you know she had
a little
kind of rambunctious day
and just talked to her about it no big
deal
the next morning
her mother said to me
she will not do that again
i had her kneel on rice for three mo
three hours
saying oh my goodness um
some prayers
i felt
terrible because
i had
no idea
that
i'm really i was not
hard with the mother it was just like i
knew mother came here to support
bringing her school every day she was
really engaged so
i never said another word
um yeah it's those kinds of things where
we need to know more about the cultures
of the families the family yeah
yeah and
yeah that makes sense
what are some things that we can do to
you mentioned you know if uh the student
when the students in the classroom we
want them to integrate
with their peers and have those
interactions that are so important
what are things we can do to
work with students or that students
themselves can do to help make sure that
that's happening
i mean first of all i think
the teacher sets the example
and if
you are setting an example
that this child is
not being distinguished
they may be getting some assistance they
may be
sitting in a different place in the
classroom
but it's to
allow
for the students to really
learn and respect
different ways that children learn
and um
i think
depending on the age
younger children really are
pretty into accepting each other
and
if there is any bullying going on
i think that's something which really
needs to be addressed right away
and that shouldn't be just because
typically if somebody is bullying
they're not just going to be bullying
the disabled kid
and i think you know we're
hearing that um
one of the effects
of the covet period is that
kids are exhibiting more angry behavior
in classrooms than before
so
i think it's just a mix of
what's going on some of the universities
in your area also have
teachers who are knowledgeable about
inclusive education
that's something that you also may want
to call on
and i hope that you were receiving
some education in school about working
with students who have disabilities but
by and large i think it's you treat the
student
like you treat any other student
and that sets an example for the class
about what you're expecting
through your leadership
right right that makes sense
um
we have a comment uh that that came in
from uh from uh facebook from cynthia
bailoff slava who says i feel we have
youth with invisible disabilities things
such as anxiety panic attacks social
anxiety this reminds me of your comments
especially now it seems like some of
those are there and those can can go
under the radar in our system
how do we
ensure that we're
we're making making sure we're serving
all all students who may need help
i wish i had an answer or a magic one i
think um
your your point is very well taken
and those children have and youth
have always been there
but i do think we are seeing it
in a much um more extreme way there are
more students
and um
it really is a district issue
a principal issue
meaning
really looking at
social workers and school psychologists
and others who need to be there so that
as a teacher you can be given some basic
skills
on how to be working with students like
this
who may not be identified as having a
disability
they may need to be identified
in order to be able to get appropriate
supports
but not to
pull them out of a classroom
but rather to make sure that they can
get
some accommodations that could be
helpful
so you know they could be anything from
extended school
i'm sorry extended time for testing or
i i really think
some of the flaws in our system
are now really becoming more apparent
like not having enough school social
workers or school psychologists
and you know if
you have time
it's also getting other teachers
who can really be
working with families and trying to
address
some of these issues from a fiscal
perspective
with school boards and city governments
and state government
so it's so that leads into my next
question
your history of activism is is so
impressive
how do you
advise folks to maybe start getting into
a little bit of advocacy or activism in
their communities
first of all anybody in education is an
activist
because
that's the way i feel about it you know
you have
a commitment to working
um
in a classroom
knowing that
there's all kinds of diversity
families at different income levels
different needs and in some way you know
teachers are
also a little social workers
right yeah we have lots of
responsibilities
yes um
i think
some people
you know will get active in a union
we'll get active in teacher associations
so for me the work that i've done in
advocacy
has typically not been i mean i advocate
on my own behalf
but the majority of the work that i've
done
has been collaborating with others who
have similar views
and objectives
and i think that's really what we're
talking about
is what do we need to do to ensure
that children in our classrooms
are getting the right education and in
part
that means what are we getting what do
we need as teachers
to be able to be as effective as
possible
and at the end of the day for disabled
children
my belief is
children need to be in integrated
classrooms
they need to be getting the support
so that they
are living in the world of today
and that's the other students also
see them as valuable members of the
community
and we have a range of people
with various forms of disabilities some
people don't have a good day every day
and it may be because of their
disability and it may be because of
covet and they're having more acting out
you know and we need to
i very much respect
the amount of work that goes on for a
teacher
but really i think
from an advocacy perspective
allowing people to have more of an
understanding of
what we believe can be done and what we
need in order to achieve that
fantastic
so if you did have a magic wand and
we'll get back to that magic wand what
are one or two things that you would
like to see changed about either schools
or legislation about schools or things
to to improve on where we are today
well one is that
all educators school board members
administrators principals teachers
believe that all disabled children
can learn and have the right to learn
and that the education system
has responsibility to teach
that universities are doing a better job
of training teachers
so those teachers are equipped to
effectively work
in a classroom and if they have a child
or two children or three children
whatever it may be with disabilities
that they
feel confident and that they get the
support that they need
but i think still
too many universities are not
training general ed teachers
in basic um education
to work with children who have
disabilities
and some some universities are doing
better jobs for their offering like dual
degrees early childhood and primary
education
but there's still not enough of that
going on so in what in waiving my magic
wand
it would be that academics that are
teaching
for training of teachers
really have more knowledge about
effective ways of inclusive education
which i also believe really address
issues
around race
because i think what we are seeing and
have seen for many years now is
that the biases that teachers
may have towards certain populations of
kids
may also be resulting in higher rates of
suspensions and expulsions
so
cultural competency
i think is really
difficult
honestly i also think that
salaries need to be raised
so that people like in finland
and japan and other countries
that teachers are earning and respected
for the work that you're all doing
um and i think that's something
that is not
as strong
as it needs to be
and
i'm really appreciative of
the work that most of you are doing
well
that is the end of our 30 minutes i
really appreciated all those thoughts
particularly i think that's an
interesting point about bias being
biased
across groups and thinking about where
that is
um thank you so much for joining us
today but thank you more for all of the
work you've been doing uh in activism
for learners with disabilities
look forward to seeing what you do next
and to picking up your most recent book
thank you
thank you very much
thank you interpreter